um okay here we go here's one and this
relates to this categorical data thing
this one says can be used for ordinal
but not normal or data let me say that
again
we're looking at the mode right now it
can be used for ordinal but not nominal
data hmm
let's remember which ones which I'm
ordinal is it's non numerical but
there's an order
hence ordinal right nominal data it's
just random like colors or musical
styles or those kinds of things okay so
this is saying one of these can be used
when you can add them in order but you
can't use it if it's nominal which one
do you think can be used you can talk
about medians if there's some order
there has to be some order you can't
talk about the median between blue and
brown where is that right but you can
talk about the mode what's the most
common eye color in this room that makes
sense
so this one I'll say it one more time so
you can write it now can be used for
ordinal but not nominal data that
belongs over here under medium okay
these two are right with left in there
I've left this one because the jury's
out on that one okay
next one along I can't hit this one
should be on controversial easiest to
determine do we think the modes easy to
determine yeah sure like you've got to
do your addition and division here this
one you've got to do your business about
counting along and all that this one you
kind of just count them up whichever the
most dark you're there okay okay here's
another one may exercise is a long one
but I couldn't work out a way if you can
work out a way to make this more
succinct tell me may not always be a
score that's anywhere near the center of
the set I'll say that again may not
always be a score anywhere near the
center of the set do we think that's the
mode can someone give me an example of
where that might happen or how them I
haven't said yes right yeah may not
always be a score that's anywhere near
the center of the circle Jackie
right sure
one two three four five ten ten tens the
mode and it's nowhere near the center of
all the rest of the dots so I think
we're happy with that one may not always
be a score anywhere near the center mmm
here's an interesting one okay this one
requires us to remember some language we
haven't talked about this year yet it's
only day two highly consistent when
comparing samples can someone remind me
what a sample is perfect right when you
take a grip not the whole thing what's
the opposite of a sample man
a census means everyone is included
everyone's included and a sample is when
you just say well let's have a look at
this class not the whole school or
something like that
okay so one of these three is most
consistent when comparing samples it's
like if I look at this class or that
course it's most consistent do we think
it's the mean or modal meaning it's
currently under mode samples right so
this is the idea that you've got 25
million people you're like I can't ask
all of them take me forever right so
I'll just ask a section but so long as I
pick the section appropriately I should
get consistent results no matter whether
I get this section or that section or
that section what do you think would it
be mean why do you think that
is it an order so it's a great question
actually I'm going to throw that
question to everyone when you tweet
about a sample right are you asking is
the sample in order questions if we have
everyone right if we have everyone is it
a good sample if we take them all from
like one area and all very similar
versus another no you don't we have a
name for that by the way that means your
samples not very representative of your
whole group so if that's the whole point
right so we think it's me if we have
representative samples then the whole
point is heartfully okay we'll do this
right by the way recent history has
given us plenty of counter examples out
because it's really hard to get a
representative sample for example a few
little things like the recent federal
election the Briggs at referendum the US
election all got it wrong okay
that's because it's quite hard as it
turns out to get good samples right but
if you do the mean is highly consistent
why is that by the way the things have
reach out don't they're right it's like
we look at a class you've got some above
average height people but they'll be
averaged out with the below after the
shorter people it makes sort of its
sense right there's a contrast to that
all right
didya do you like that I will because
we've now moved it so now you want to
write it it says highly consistent
highly consistent when comparing samples
we have a name for that by the way it's
called sample stability which makes
sense right depend on which sample you
look at you get a stable response either
way there's a contrast to this one you
might guess it's the opposite I'm just
trying to find where it is here it is
varies the most when comparing samples
varies the most when comparing samples
so this one say doesn't vary much this
one says it does which of the three well
which are the two you know it's not this
one which of these two do you think
varies the most when comparing
it says varies the most when comparing
samples
hmm forty record my region as the median
is listed in order it has to be where as
Modi doesn't really have to be you just
have to figure out the most common
number so which do you think at ball so
if you think I'll comes in a second what
if you think of beginning and the median
you're gonna have a small range of
numbers big range of numbers mm-hmm so
before us once that will you already
said okay I want you to say that again I
don't even want you to change what you
said you have to said exactly I want you
to say again but I just want everyone to
pay close attention to wills logic not
just his words okay so not bad okay now
let's just confirm what will said right
and I'll give you an illustration of
this okay will suggestion is for which
one of these varies the most when
comparing samples his suggestion is the
mode okay now I think he's correct and
I'll give you the example that um Zack
he gave actually just now what was it
something like one two three four five
and then say for the sake of argument
you've got two tens okay now the reason
why it's so easy to get a weird mood for
something like this
do you agree it's because there's not
many scores right if you had like loads
more scores it would be more and more
unlikely that you have something unusual
like this in fact this is more likely to
happen when you're deliberately making
the sample smaller do you agree right so
in fact the smaller you make your sample
the more likely this thing ends up
coincidentally just beings here
fluctuating right I could have just as
easily gone to the next room and I could
have had the room where it was like that
look at how the motors changed right but
but think about how the median is change
in fact what is the change in the media
I think it's hardly gone anywhere has it
because the mineral score is still more
or less in the same place does that make
sense okay fantastic so well not suppose
I did it was a sample of a bunch of
other scores right like to say I had 100
scores and I just picked out seven so
the whole point of getting a sample is
to try and avoid all of this is kind of
pointless right that's exactly right so
we want samples to always be
representative if our sample is not
representative then actually none of
this matters like you as all those
results showed okay makes sense do you
see where we go that we're assuming it's
a good sample okay all right then I just
moved over okay so that one I just put
on the median so you know what mode
sorry so you know what to write varies
the most when comparing samples the mode
is the one that varies the most when you
change from sample to sample and this is
this is an example just get okay now it
looks like we're pretty close we already
put these two deliberately under median
you should have two they're usually
unaffected by outliers and can be used
for ordinal not normal data that means
this one which I just took away from
here is in the wrong spot you're going
to help me work out where it belongs it
says it's the only measure that can be
used on all categorical data I'll say
that again one of these measures is the
only one that no matter what kind of
categorical data you've got icarly shoe
size whatever you can still use this
which one is it
it's the mode isn't it because it
requires no calculation you're just
counting up okay so the mode I'll say
all the time is the only measure that
can be used on all categorical data